TODAY WE HAVE, ONE BILL AND SIX
TRIBAL STATE COMPACTS AND ONE
COMPACT. COMPACT EXTENSION. I
WANT TO REMIND MEMBERS AND STAFF
THAT WE ONLY HAVE ONE
RESOLUTION. I ASK THAT MEMBERS
MAKE THEIR WAY TO THE COMMITTEE
SO WE CAN DO THE PEOPLE'S
BUSINESS. AS SOON AS WE DISPERSE
WITH THE RESOLUTION WILL BE
ADJOURNING OUR BILL, HEARING AND
MOVING FORWARD WITH OUR COMPACT
HEARINGS. WITH THAT, LET'S BEGIN
WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE, ACR
151 ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON.
WELCOME. AND PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
BEGIN. ONE MORE. DOLLY. DOLLY.
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU, MISTER CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT ACR 151, WHICH SEEKS TO
RAISE AWARENESS AND PRIORITIZE
THE USE OF SEISMICALLY VETTED
NONSTRUCTURAL COMPONENTS WITHIN
OUR BUILDINGS. NONSTRUCTURAL
COMPONENTS CAN INCLUDE PLUMBING,
ELECTRICAL, WIRING, AND HVAC
SYSTEMS, ALL OF WHICH ARE
SEPARATE FROM STRUCTURAL
BUILDING COMPONENTS SUCH AS THE
FOUNDATION OF A BUILDING OR LOAD
BEARING WALLS. THE NONSTRUCTURAL
COMPONENTS WITHIN OUR BUILDINGS
PLAY A MAJOR YET UNDERESTIMATED
ROLE IN SEISMIC RESILIENCY.
FOLLOWING AN EARTHQUAKE,
BUILDINGS ARE OFTEN RENDERED
INHOSPITABLE DUE TO SEVERE
DAMAGE TO THE NONSTRUCTURAL
SYSTEMS. DESPITE MINIMAL DAMAGE
TO THE STRUCTURAL COMPONENTS.
GIVEN THE CONSTANT THREAT OF
EARTHQUAKES IN OUR STATE AND WE
HAD A, WE HAD A COUPLE YESTERDAY
RIGHT BY MY HOME. ACR 151 SEEKS
TO RAISE THE IMPORTANCE OF
SEISMICALLY VETTED NONSTRUCTURAL
TECHNOLOGIES FROM THE POINT OF
NEW CONSTRUCTION TO THE
FUNCTIONAL RECOVERY OF A
BUILDING POST-EARTHQUAKE. HERE
WITH ME IN SUPPORT IS RICHARD
MCCARTHY, PRESIDENT OF THE
EARTHQUAKE ENGINEERING RESEARCH
INSTITUTE, NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
DIVISION, AND TOM SHEEHY, ON
BEHALF OF THE PIPE MANUFACTURING
COMPANY OMEGA FLEX. Þ. PERFECT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING, MISTER CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS, THANK YOU FOR HEARING
ME THIS MORNING, TO BUILD ON
WHAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS
SAID TO YOU, THE NONSTRUCTURAL
COMPONENTS OF BUILDINGS ARE KIND
OF AN UNDERESTIMATED, LIABILITY.
THOSE COMPONENTS CAN KNOCK YOU
OUT AND GET YOU RED TAGGED OR
YELLOW TAGGED AND AFFECTS YOUR
BUILDING'S FUNCTIONALITY. SO
WHAT WE NEED IS YOUR ASSISTANCE
HERE IS TO IDENTIFY THOSE
COMPANIES AND ENTITIES THAT HAVE
GONE THE EXTRA MILE TO
SEISMICALLY TEST THEIR
COMPONENTS. AND AS AN EXAMPLE,
FINAL POINT IS WE HAVE A LARGE
SEISMIC TEST IN AT UC SAN DIEGO.
TEN STORY BUILDING STEEL MOMENT
FRAME FULL OF NONSTRUCTURAL
COMPONENTS THAT WILL BE SHAKING
SHAKING THOSE THAT THAT ENTITY
AND DOING POST-EARTHQUAKE FIRE
TESTS AS WELL. SO THESE ARE
SOPHISTICATED TESTS AND IT'S UP
TO US TO TRY AND RECOGNIZE THOSE
COMPANIES BY ALLOWING POTENTIAL
BUILDING OWNERS AND CONTRACTORS
TO IDENTIFY AND USE THOSE
COMPONENTS. THEY DON'T COST ANY
MORE THAN ANY OTHER COMPONENT.
SO IT, IT IMPROVES THE
FUNCTIONALITY AND, SHALL WE SAY,
RESILIENCY OF THE BUILDING. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'RE GOING TO PAUSE AT THIS
POINT. DO A QUORUM CALL.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DODD. HERE. WILK PRESENT WILK.
PRESENT. ARCHULETA. ASHBY. HERE.
ASHBY. HERE. BRADFORD YES.
BRADFORD. HERE. GLASER JONES.
HERE. JONES. HERE. NGUYEN OKOBO.
OKOBO. HERE. PADILLA PORTANTINO.
HERE. PORTANTINO HERE. ROTH.
HERE. ROTH. HERE. RUBIO.
PRESENT. RUBIO. PRESENT HERE.
SIERRA. HERE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
PERFECT. WE HAVE A QUORUM.
PLEASE PROCEED. GREAT. THANK
YOU. CHAIRMAN DODD AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE A FEW WORDS HERE IN SUPPORT
OF MISS CALDERON'S RESOLUTION.
CALIFORNIA IS EARTHQUAKE
COUNTRY. THERE'S NO QUESTION
ABOUT IT. WE'VE HAD SEVERAL
EARTHQUAKES OVER 4.0 ON THE
RICHTER SCALE JUST IN THE LAST
TEN DAYS. AND MOST EARTHQUAKE
REGULATIONS AND BUILDING CODE
REQUIREMENTS FOCUS ON THE
STRUCTURAL ASPECT OF BUILDINGS.
MISS CALDERON'S RESOLUTION
FOCUSES ON THE NON STRUCTURAL
PART. AND WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
NONSTRUCTURAL WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THINGS LIKE ELEVATORS,
STAIRWELLS, HVAC SYSTEMS,
ELECTRICAL SYSTEMS AND PIPING
SYSTEMS. THESE ARE CRITICAL
BECAUSE IF A BUILDING IS LEFT
INTACT STANDING AFTER AN
EARTHQUAKE AND THEIR WATER PIPES
BREAK AND FLOOD THE BUILDING, IT
BECOMES UNUSABLE. JUST AS AN
EXAMPLE OF HOW A NON STRUCTURAL
SYSTEM CAN CAUSE HAVOC IN A
BUILDING. SO HAVING A FOCUS ON
THE NON STRUCTURAL ELEMENTS OF
SEISMIC SAFETY IS A REALLY,
REALLY IMPORTANT MATTER. ACR 151
ADDRESSES THIS CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE BENEFITS
THAT IT CAN BRING BY TRYING TO
JUMPSTART MORE WORK IN THIS AREA
WITH NON STRUCTURAL SYSTEMS,
SEISMIC CODES AND STANDARDS DO
EXIST THAT WILL FACILITATE THE
USE OF MORE RESILIENT BUILDING
COMPONENTS. BUT WE NEED TO HAVE
MORE INCENTIVES IN ORDER TO GET
ENGINEERS TO TAKE THESE UP. AND
WE'RE HOPING THAT ACR 151 WILL
SEND A MESSAGE TO THE BUILDING
COMMUNITY, AND TO ENGINEERS AND
TO BUILDING DESIGNERS TO USE
MORE OF THESE MATERIALS, CHANGES
IN BUILDING STANDARDS ARE
HAPPENING ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND SO WE THINK THIS IS A REALLY
GOOD OPPORTUNITY TO SEND A
MESSAGE TO THE BUILDING CODE
COMMUNITY SUCH AS IT IS, THERE
ARE NO CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC COSTS
TO THIS MEASURE. WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT IT WILL MAKE
BUILDINGS MORE EXPENSIVE TO
BUILD OR MAINTAIN. IN FACT, WE
THINK IN THE LONG RUN OVER THE
LIFE CYCLE OF A BUILDING HAVING
MORE RESILIENT COMPONENTS AND IT
WILL ACTUALLY SAVE COSTS, THIS
IS A SMALL STEP, BUT WE THINK AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN THE DIRECTION
OF MORE SEISMIC RESILIENCY AND
FUNCTIONAL RECOVERY. AND WE
WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
THIS MORNING IN YOUR AYE VOTE ON
MISS CALDERON'S RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN SUPPORT?
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
WILK. I DO LIKE TO SAY I REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS IN 2013, I WAS A
NAPA COUNTY SUPERVISOR AFTER THE
EARTHQUAKES IN NAPA AND MY WIFE
AND I, ABOUT 5:00 IN THE
MORNING, WALKED UP TO THE COUNTY
BUILDING THE STAIRS, BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY THE ELEVATORS WERE NOT
WORKING. AND WHAT WHAT WAS
REALLY EVIDENT TO US IS THERE
WAS NO STRUCTURAL DAMAGE IN THIS
BIG BUILDING AT ALL. BUT WHAT
WAS HAPPENING IS ALL THE PIPING
WAS BROKEN WATER SPRAYING OUT,
YOU KNOW, ON THE STAIRS GOING UP
THE HVAC SYSTEMS, ALL THE
THINGS, YOU KNOW, HANGING THERE.
SO I, I DO THINK THIS IS A
SERIOUS ISSUE AND MUCH DAMAGE
WAS DONE TO THAT BUILDING, BY
WATER AND, AND OTHER ELEMENTS.
AND IF WE'D HAD A GOOD
INFRASTRUCTURE THERE, THERE
WOULD HAVE BEEN A LOT LESS
DAMAGE TO HAVE TO PAY FOR IT
LATER. SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD. WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR WILK, THE MOTION IS
THAT THE RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EXCUSE ME. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? YES. THANK YOU. I JUST
CLOSED FOR YOU. YES. I
APPRECIATE THAT, MR. CHAIR.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. SO, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. DODD. AYE DODD
AYE. WILK AYE. WILK AYE.
ARCHULETA. ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY
AYE. BRADFORD AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
GLAZER. JONES A. JONES. AYE.
NGUYEN OKUBO. AYE. OKUBO AYE.
PADILLA PORTANTINO. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE ROTH. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. RUBIO AYE. SALADO. AYE.
ZERO. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AS
TEN VOTES, WE'LL HOLD THE ROLL.
WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THE ROLL.
THE ROLL IS NOW CLOSED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MR.
CHAIR. TERRIFIC SO WE'RE
ADJOURNING OUR BILL HEARING AND
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS. ONCE
AGAIN GOOD MORNING. I'M SENATOR
DODD, CHAIRMAN OF THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE TODAY WILL BE HOLDING
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS ON ONE
TRIBAL COMPACT EXTENSION AS WELL
AS SIX TRIBAL STATE COMPACTS.
WE'LL BEGIN WITH THE TRIBAL
COMPACT EXTENSION, FOLLOWED IN
ALPHABETICAL ORDER BY SIX TRIBAL
STATE GAMING COMPACTS LISTED ON
THE AGENDA. FOR THOSE OF YOU
UNFAMILIAR WITH THE SENATE'S
PROCEDURE, THE ESTABLISHED
POLICY ALLOWS FOR INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON THE DETAILS OF THE
COMPACT TO BE FOLLOWED BY A VOTE
ON THE SENATE FLOOR. NO VOTE
WILL BE TAKEN HERE TODAY AS AN
EXAMPLE, THE BILL RATIFYING THE
CAMPO ELEM INDIAN COLONY, LA
POSTA TIMBISHA COMPACTS, WILL BE
SB 931 BY YOURS TRULY, ASSUMING
EVERYTHING GOES SMOOTHLY. SB 931
WILL SOON BE AMENDED WITH
RATIFYING LANGUAGE FOR ALL FOUR
OF THOSE COMPACTS TAKEN UP BY
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR. ONCE THAT
BILL COMES TO THE SENATE, THE
BILL WILL BE REFERRED STRAIGHT
TO THE SENATE FLOOR FOR A VOTE,
WITH THE FULL SENATE BODY. WITH
THAT, LET'S BEGIN OUR
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THE
AUGUSTINE EXTENSION. AUGUSTINE
EXTENSION. EXCUSE ME. I WANT TO
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO WELCOME
MATTHEW LEE TO HIS FIRST
PRESENTATION ON TRIBAL COMPACTS
AND CONGRATULATE HIM FOR THIS
APPOINTMENT AS SENIOR ADVISOR
FOR TRIBAL NEGOTIATIONS FOR
GOVERNOR NEWSOM. MR. LEE, PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO BEGIN. WELL, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, CHAIR. GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING. HONORABLE
MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING ME HERE THIS MORNING.
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE. AND
OF COURSE, I'D LIKE TO WISH A
VERY WARM GOOD MORNING TO THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS AND OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO HAVE ALSO JOINED
US. FIRST, PERHAPS JUST A LITTLE
BIT OF TABLE SETTING THAT MIGHT
HELP US THROUGH ALL OF THESE
ITEMS. I KNOW THAT WHAT I AM
ABOUT TO SAY IS NOT NEWS TO THIS
COMMITTEE, BUT FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO ARE FOLLOWING ALONG AT HOME,
IT MIGHT BE HELPFUL TO KNOW THE
BASIC FRAMEWORK HERE. THE
STARTING POINT FOR RELATIONS
BETWEEN THE STATE GOVERNMENT AND
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS IS THAT BOTH
ARE, IN FACT THEIR OWN SOVEREIGN
GOVERNMENTS. NEITHER HAS THE
GENERAL MATTER ANY INHERENT
POWER TO REGULATE THE OTHER. BUT
BOTH DO RELATE TO EACH OTHER ON
A GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT BASIS.
THERE IS, WITHOUT SORT OF
BELABORING THE FINER POINTS OF
THE RELEVANT FEDERAL LAW. HERE
THERE IS A SPECIFIC FEDERAL
STATUTE THAT PROVIDES A
FRAMEWORK FOR THE STATE
GOVERNMENT AND TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS TO STRUCTURE THEIR
RELATIONSHIPS IN THE SPECIFIC
CONTEXT OF TRIBAL GAMING. IT'S
CALLED THE INDIAN GAMING
REGULATORY ACT. AND WHAT THAT
FEDERAL STATUTE SAYS IS THAT THE
STATE GOVERNMENT AND TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN COME TOGETHER
AND WORK TO NEGOTIATE ABOUT
CERTAIN TOPICS THAT ARE SOMEHOW
RELATED TO GAMING, SO THAT THE
TRIBE CAN, PURSUE THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND SELF-SUFFICIENCY
THAT GAMING PROVIDES. AND THE
STATE CAN MANAGE THE POTENTIAL
ADVERSE IMPACTS AND OTHER
EXTERNALITIES THAT MAY BE
FLOWING FROM TRIBAL GAMING. SO
THAT'S THAT'S THE BASIC
FOUNDATION FOR ALL OF THE
COMPACTS THAT YOU ARE GOING TO
HEAR ABOUT THIS MORNING. THESE
ARE COMPACTS WHERE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND ITS
PARTNERS REPRESENTING THE STATE
HAVE WORKED TO, TO NEGOTIATE FOR
CERTAIN PRIORITIES THAT WE
BELIEVE ARE IMPORTANT TO PROTECT,
LEGITIMATE STATE INTERESTS,
THINGS LIKE THE PROTECTION OF
WORKERS IN TRIBAL CASINOS. AND
SO ON. AND, OF COURSE, THE TRIBE
HAS DONE ITS BEST TO STRIKE A
DEAL THAT WILL MAXIMIZE ITS
OPPORTUNITY FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. SO I'LL SAY MORE
ABOUT ALL OF THOSE DETAILS AS WE
DISCUSS EACH COMPACT. FOR
PURPOSES OF THE AUGUSTINE
EXTENSION, I JUST WANT TO FLAG
THAT THIS IS IN A DIFFERENT
POSTURE THAN THE OTHER COMPACTS.
YOU WILL HEAR THIS MORNING WHAT
WE HAVE HERE IS A SITUATION
WHERE, IF THE TRIBE AND THE
STATE ARE UNABLE TO REACH A DEAL
UNDER THE FRAMEWORK, I JUST
DESCRIBED, ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT CAN HAPPEN IS THAT THEY CAN
WIND UP IN LITIGATION, AND THERE
IS A COMPLICATED PROCEDURE THAT
THAT THAT PROCESS CAN FOLLOW.
BUT THE SHORT VERSION IS THAT
THAT IS WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN THE
CONTEXT OF AUGUSTINE. BOTH
PARTIES HAVE GOTTEN A RULING
FROM A FEDERAL DISTRICT COURT
THAT FAVORED ONE SIDE ON SOME
ISSUES AND FAVORED THE OTHER
SIDE ON SOME OTHER ISSUES. WE
ARE NOW BOTH ENGAGED IN A
MANDATORY PROCESS OF FURTHER
NEGOTIATIONS THAT FOLLOWS THAT
RULING. AND OF COURSE, BOTH
SIDES COULD BE CONSIDERING OTHER
LEGAL OPTIONS AS WELL. THE SHORT
VERSION IS THAT BECAUSE THAT
PROCESS IS CONTINUING AND
BECAUSE WE ARE DEALING WITH A
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT THAT HAS AN
EXISTING GAMING COMPACT AND AN
EXISTING GAMING OPERATION IN
PLACE, FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE, IT
MAKES SENSE TO SIMPLY PRESERVE
THE STATUS QUO BY EXTENDING THAT
EXISTING COMPACT. WHILE THE
ONGOING LEGAL PROCESS THAT I
JUST DESCRIBED CONTINUES. SO
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT THIS
EXTENSION WOULD DO TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR. LEE.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FOR
MEMBERS? OKAY. I JUST HAVE ONE.
I UNDERSTAND THERE'S POSSIBILITY
THAT OTHER EXTENSIONS MIGHT BE
GETTING DONE THIS SESSION. DO
YOU HAVE AN UPDATE ON THOSE? AND
WHEN THEY POTENTIALLY MAY BE
FINALIZED? YES, ABSOLUTELY. AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, BOTH FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND FOR ASKING
ABOUT THAT. MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THE LAST TWO THAT THE THAT
THAT I HAVE BEEN TRACKING,
SHOULD BE DELIVERED TODAY,
THAT'S THE TRINIDAD RANCHERIA UP
IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY AND THE
PICAYUNE RANCHERIA OF THE
CHUKCHI SEA DOWN IN COARSEGOLD.
I DON'T ANTICIPATE FURTHER
EXTENSIONS AT THIS TIME, BUT OF
COURSE WILL BE IN TOUCH WITH
STAFF AS THE SITUATION DEVELOPS.
PERFECT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO CHAIR THE
CHAIRWOMAN FROM AUGUSTINE, WHO I
BELIEVE IS ON ZOOM. CHAIRMAN,
ARE YOU THERE? CHAIRWOMAN, ARE
YOU THERE? EXCUSE ME.
OH, THERE YOU ARE. GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING. I AM THE
CHAIRPERSON FOR THE TIMBISHA
SHOSHONE TRIBE. WELL, WE'LL BE
WE'LL BE VISITING WITH YOU
MOMENTARILY. WE'RE LOOKING FOR
THE CHAIRWOMAN FROM AUGUSTINE.
PLEASE. I DON'T DO ANYMORE. SHE
DOES. EVERYTHING COMES IN. AND
NOW, A WORD FROM OUR SPONSOR,
NAPA VALLEY WINE. YEAH. WHAT'S
THAT? OKAY, WE'LL MOVE ON. SURE.
SHE HAD A LOT TO SAY, BUT ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS? I DON'T
THINK THERE COULD BE ANY
QUESTIONS. WE HAVEN'T HEARD
ANYTHING FROM THEM, SO WE'LL
MOVE ON. ANYONE WANTING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN
THE ROOM. SEEING NONE. THAT
CONCLUDES OUR INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON THE AUGUSTINE
AUGUSTINE COMPACT EXTENSION.
WE'LL NOW MOVE TO THE BIG SANDY
COMPACT. MR. LEE, PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO BEGIN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ON THIS COMPACT, THIS IS A
NEW, SUBSTANTIVE, COMPACT FOR A
TRIBE DOWN IN, I BELIEVE, FRESNO
COUNTY, AND GIVES ME AN
OPPORTUNITY TO INTRODUCE SOME OF
THE KEY TERMS THAT ARE AT ISSUE
WHENEVER WE, AS A STATE, WORK TO
NEGOTIATE THESE COMPACTS, OF
COURSE, SOME OF THE KEY TERMS
ARE, RELATIVELY FUNDAMENTAL TO
THE WHOLE PROJECT OF OPERATING A
GAMING OPERATION. HOW MANY
MACHINES, HOW MANY FACILITIES IN
THIS CASE, IT'S A CAP OF 3000
GAMING DEVICES. YOU KNOW, THINGS
LIKE SLOT MACHINES AT NO MORE
THAN TWO FACILITIES, SOME OF THE
OTHER KEY TERMS THAT TEND TO
COME UP IN ALL OF THESE,
NEGOTIATIONS, CONCERN WHAT YOU
MIGHT THINK OF AS THE ECONOMIC
REALITIES OF THE GAMING
OPERATION. AND IT'S, REGULATION
IN TWO KEY RESPECTS. THERE IS
SOMETHING CALLED THE SPECIAL
DISTRIBUTION FUND. THESE ARE
PAYMENTS THAT TRIBAL GAMING
OPERATIONS MAKE TO THE STATE.
THEY ARE INTENDED TO COVER THE
STATE'S REGULATORY COSTS. THERE
IS A SPECIAL FORMULA THAT THE
STATE HAS OVER MANY YEARS WORKED
OUT, TO HELP DEFINE WHAT THOSE
COSTS ARE AND HOW THEY CAN BE
COVERED. THAT'S THE SAME FORMULA
THAT WE'RE USING HERE IN BIG
SANDY, EXCEPT THAT, WELL, BIG
SANDY REMAINS WHAT'S CALLED A
LIMITED GAMING TRIBE. UNDER 350
DEVICES. THEY CAN PAY USING AN
OLDER FORMULA UNDER THEIR
PREEXISTING 1999 COMPACT. DON'T
SEE THAT AS A SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCE, BUT IT IS SOMETHING
THAT THE FROM THE STATE'S
PERSPECTIVE. BUT IT IS SOMETHING
THAT THE TRIBE DID, NEGOTIATE
FOR. THERE'S A SEPARATE, BUCKET
OF ECONOMIC TERMS. THERE'S A
SEPARATE SET OF PAYMENTS CALLED
THE REVENUE SHARING TRUST FUND,
OR THE RCF AND THE TRIBAL NATION
GRANT FUND, OR TANF. THESE ARE
PAYMENTS THAT ARE ADMINISTERED
BY THE STATE. I DON'T THINK IT'S
QUITE RIGHT TO THINK OF THEM AS
PAYMENTS TO THE STATE, THESE ARE
PAYMENTS THAT THE STATE
ADMINISTERS ON BEHALF OF OTHER
TRIBAL NATIONS. PART OF THE,
PART OF THE GOAL OF THE ENTIRE
TRIBAL GAMING FRAMEWORK HERE.
AND THE FEDERAL LAW UNDERLYING
IT IS THAT TRIBAL GAMING IS
MEANT TO SUPPORT ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT, NOT JUST FOR, YOU
KNOW, A HANDFUL OF SPECIFIC
TRIBES, BUT FOR TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS IN GENERAL. AND SO
ONE OF THE WAYS IN WHICH, FOR
DECADES NOW, THE STATE AND
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE SOUGHT
TO WORK TOGETHER TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN, TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
BENEFITS OF TRIBAL GAMING FLOW
TO A LARGE NUMBER OF TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS ACROSS THE BOARD IS
BY ADMINISTERING THESE TWO
FUNDS, WHICH, IN THE SIMPLEST
VERSION, PROVIDE FOR GRANT
PAYMENTS TO, NON-GAMING AND
LIMITED GAMING TRIBES, THE STAFF
TERMS IN THE BIG SANDY COMPACT
ARE WITHIN THE REALM OF WHAT
THIS BODY HAS PROBABLY SEEN
BEFORE. THEY PAY NOTHING BELOW
1200 DEVICES AND THEN THERE'S A
SCALED SERIES OF STAFF
CONTRIBUTIONS ABOVE THAT 1200
DEVICE THRESHOLD, THEY WILL
ALSO, PAY, 1% OF NET NGUYEN TO
MITIGATE LOCAL IMPACTS. THE, YOU
KNOW, POTENTIAL LOCAL REGULATORY
COSTS AND OTHER POTENTIAL LOCAL
NEGATIVE EXTERNALITIES OF
RUNNING A GAMING OPERATION. THEY
WILL, IF THEY EXPAND BEYOND THAT
350 DEVICE THRESHOLD. I
MENTIONED EARLIER, THEY WILL PAY
INTO A LOCAL IMPACT, MITIGATION
FUND TO HELP DEFRAY THOSE,
WITHOUT BELABORING THE POINT,
THEY ARE REQUIRED TO CARRY
INSURANCE TO PROTECT, CASINO
PATRONS IN THE EVENT OF, AN
INCIDENT, YOU KNOW, HARMING A
CASINO PATRON, YOU KNOW, GENERAL
TORT LIABILITY, THINGS LIKE
THAT. HAPPY TO SAY MORE ABOUT
THAT IF IT'S HELPFUL. THEY ARE
ALSO REQUIRED TO CARRY
EMPLOYMENT SPECIFIC INSURANCE TO
PROTECT WORKERS. THEIR WORKERS
ARE ALSO PROTECTED BY A RANGE OF
NOW STANDARD COMPACT TERMS
PROTECTING CASINO WORKERS. IN
THIS CONTEXT, THINGS LIKE STATE,
MINIMUM WAGE. AND SO ON. THERE
IS ALSO WHAT'S CALLED A TRIBAL
LABOR RELATIONS ORDINANCE, WHICH
FOR GAMING OPERATIONS OVER A
CERTAIN THRESHOLD, TYPICALLY
ABOUT 250 EMPLOYEES, PROVIDES A
STRUCTURE AND A FRAMEWORK TO
FACILITATE THE REPRESENTATION BY
A LABOR UNION OF THOSE CASINO
EMPLOYEES. SO FURTHER, YOU KNOW,
FURTHER, FRAMEWORK FOR WORKER
PROTECTIONS. THEY'RE HAPPY TO
SAY MORE ABOUT ANY OF THOSE
TERMS OR ANYTHING ELSE IN THE
COMPACT. BUT THOSE ARE WHAT I
SEE AS THE SORT OF KEY TERMS OF
THIS COMPACT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
SEEING NONE. THANK YOU, MR. LEE,
I'M GOING TO MOVE NOW TO
CHAIRWOMAN KIPP, WHO I BELIEVE
IS ON ZOOM. YES. GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRWOMAN. GOOD
MORNING, MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
KIPP. I'M THE CHAIRPERSON OF BIG
SANDY RANCHERIA OF WESTERN MONO
INDIANS. I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY
REGARDING OUR TRIBAL STATE
GAMING COMPACT WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE LEGISLATION.
AB 2032, INTRODUCED BY
ASSEMBLYMAN PATTERSON TO RATIFY
THIS COMPACT AS SENATOR SHANNON
GROVE IS THE PRINCIPAL COAUTHOR.
BIG SANDY RANCHERIA IS
HEADQUARTERED IN AUBERRY,
CALIFORNIA. OUR TRUST LANDS
INCLUDE THE BIG SANDY RANCHERIA
AND ADDITIONAL PARCELS EAST OF
FRESNO. OUR TRIBE HAS A RICH
HISTORY IN CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL
REGION, TRADITIONALLY INHABITING
THE SIERRA NEVADA AREAS. WE HAVE
A STRONG CULTURAL HERITAGE KNOWN
FOR OUR BASKETRY SKILLS AND
HUNTER GATHERER LIFESTYLE.
TODAY, WE ARE COMMITTED TO
PRESERVING OUR LANGUAGE,
CULTURE, AND TRADITIONS WHILE
PURSUING ECONOMIC VENUES
INCLUDING GAMING AND INTERTRIBAL
COMMERCE. THIS COMPACT SIGNIFIES
A PIVOTAL MOMENT FOR OUR TRIBE
AND BRINGS WITH IT THE PROMISE
OF SUBSTANTIAL BENEFITS TO OUR
TRIBAL MEMBERS AND THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY. THE
COMPACT INCLUDES PROVISIONS THAT
DIRECTLY BENEFIT OUR TRIBAL
MEMBERS BY ENSURING THE
SUSTAINABILITY AND GROWTH OF OUR
ECONOMIC VENTURES AS A LONG TERM
COMPACT OF 25 YEARS, WE WILL
HAVE THE ABILITY FOR STRATEGIC
PLANNING AND INVESTMENTS IN OUR
EDUCATION, HEALTH CARE,
GOVERNMENT SERVICES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
ADDITIONALLY, OUR TRIBE ENJOYS
STRONG SUPPORT FROM FRESNO
COUNTY AND THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE.
WE HAVE ENJOYED A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT IN ENSURING COMMUNITY
SAFETY AND ADDRESSING SHARED
CONCERNS WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT
LEADERS. FOR THIS REASON, I'D
LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THAT UNDER
THIS COMPACT, WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED AN IMPACT MITIGATION
FUND, WHICH HAS DEDICATED TO
SUPPORTING LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT, EMERGENCY SERVICES
AND NEIGHBORING JURISDICTIONS.
THIS FUND ENSURES THAT
NEIGHBORING JURISDICTIONS HAVE
THE NECESSARY RESOURCES TO
ADDRESS ANY IMPACTS ARISING FROM
OUR GAMING FACILITIES, THE
RATIFICATION OF OUR GAMING
COMPACT THROUGH AB 2032 IS VITAL
FOR THE CONTINUED GROWTH AND
PROSPERITY OF THE BIG SANDY
RANCHERIA. THIS COMPACT NOT ONLY
FACILITATES ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT, BUT ALSO ENSURES
THAT WE CAN ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
OUR COMMUNITY AND NEIGHBORING
JURISDICTIONS EFFECTIVELY. THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDERING MY TESTIMONY
AND FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AB 2036.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. CHAIR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. CHAIRWOMAN KIP, I
APPRECIATE THAT. ANY QUESTIONS
FROM ANY MEMBERS HERE SEEING
NONE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. THIS
MORNING, THAT CONCLUDES OUR INFO
HEARING ON THE BIG SANDY
COMPACT. WE'LL NOW MOVE TO THE
CAMPO COMPACT. MR. LEE, PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO BEGIN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ON THE CAMPO COMPACT,
THIS IS A 1200 DEVICE. COMPACT.
SO SOMEWHAT SMALLER THAN BIG
SANDY, SAME, SPECIAL
DISTRIBUTION FUND, PRO-RATA
FORMULA. THAT'S THE STATE'S
REGULATORY COSTS, IF THE TRIBE
REMAINS WHERE, WHERE IT IS NOW
IN TERMS OF BEING WHAT'S CALLED
A LIMITED GAMING TRIBE THAT'S
UNDER THAT 350 DEVICE THRESHOLD
I MENTIONED EARLIER, IT IS
ELIGIBLE TO HAVE THAT SDF
CONTRIBUTION REDUCED OR
ELIMINATED AS LONG, OF COURSE,
AS THERE IS SUFFICIENT MONEY IN
THE SPECIAL DISTRIBUTION FUND TO
COVER THAT BECAUSE IT IS A
COMPACT THAT CAPS OUT AT 1200
DEVICES, WHICH IS THE SORT OF
USUAL THRESHOLD FOR PAYMENTS
INTO THE REVENUE SHARING TRUST
FUND. I MENTIONED EARLIER, THE
FUND THAT, CONSISTS OF PAYMENTS
TO OTHER NON GAMING AND LIMITED
GAMING TRIBES. WE DON'T NEED TO
WORRY ABOUT THE RCF IN THE
CONTEXT OF THIS COMPACT BECAUSE
OF THAT 1200 DEVICE CAP, IT HAS,
SIMILAR EMPLOYEE PROTECTIONS,
SOME ADDITIONAL, EMPLOYEE
PROTECTIONS HERE BASED ON,
CALIFORNIA LAW TO PROVIDE FOR
THE PROTECTION OF OFF
RESERVATION EMPLOYEES, SIMILAR
INSURANCE THRESHOLDS, SIMILAR
TORTS, LANGUAGE. AND OF COURSE,
IT MAINTAINS THE TRIBAL LABOR
RELATIONS ORDINANCE. I MENTIONED
EARLIER. THOSE ARE THE
HIGHLIGHTS. HAPPY TO GO INTO ANY
OF THAT IN FURTHER DETAIL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR. LEE. ANY
QUESTIONS? SEEING NONE, WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO ANYONE WANTING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS ON THIS
COMPACT, SEEING NOBODY COMING
FORWARD. THAT CONCLUDES OUR INFO
HEARING ON THE CAMPO BAND
COMPACT. WE'LL NOW MOVE TO THE
ELEM INDIAN COLONY COMPACT. MR.
LEE, FEEL FREE TO BEGIN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND EVEN SMALLER
COMPACT THIS TIME. THIS ONE IS
UP IN THE SOUTH. CLEAR LAKE
REGION CAPS OUT AT 349. GAMING
DEVICES. SO THAT TIES INTO THAT
350 DEVICE THRESHOLD. I
MENTIONED A COUPLE OF TIMES THE
GIST OF THAT IS THAT THIS TRIBE
WILL ALWAYS BE WHAT'S CALLED A
LIMITED GAMING TRIBE. THAT, OF
COURSE, IS, MAKES THINGS
SIGNIFICANTLY SIMPLER FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF WORKING OUT THE
DETAILS OF THIS COMPACT, DON'T
NEED TO WORRY ABOUT RCF, AND
BECAUSE ITS OPERATIONS ARE SO
LIMITED, DON'T EVEN NEED TO
WORRY ABOUT THE KINDS OF LOCAL
MITIGATION EFFORTS THAT
TYPICALLY KICK IN ABOVE 350
DEVICES. THE TRIBE, OF COURSE.
COULD STILL BE SUBJECT TO
PAYMENTS INTO THE STATE SPECIAL
DISTRIBUTION FUND TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE STATE IS COVERING ITS
OWN REGULATORY COSTS AND OF
COURSE, THERE ARE STILL, PATRON,
YOU KNOW, TORT BASED PROTECTIONS,
INCLUDING INSURANCE, EMPLOYEE
PROTECTIONS, INCLUDING
INSURANCE, AND ALSO INCLUDING
TLRO. GREAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY QUESTIONS? SEEING NONE, WE
WANT TO MOVE TO ANYONE WANTING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS COMPACT. WE HAVE SOMEBODY
COMING FORWARD. GOOD MORNING.
MR. CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS JACK
DURAN. I SERVE AS THE GENERAL
COUNSEL TO THE ELEM INDIAN
COLONY. AND THANK YOU FOR THE
CORRECT PRONUNCIATION. BEING
RIGHT OVER THE HILL IN NAPA
COUNTY FROM THE TRIBE, YOU
PROBABLY GOT THAT, GOT THAT.
BEEN ABLE TO SAY THAT A COUPLE
OF TIMES. BUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR CONSIDERING THIS
COMPACT AND TAKING A LOOK AT IT.
IT'S GOING TO PROVIDE THE TRIBE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE SOME
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. THE ELEM
OR ONE OF THE OLDEST TRIBES IN
THE AREA, AND SOME OF THEIR
LANDS HAVE SETTLEMENTS THAT DATE
BACK TO 14,000 YEARS, REALLY
GOOD PEOPLE. THEY HAVE AN
EXCELLENT RELATIONSHIP WITH
THEIR COMMUNITY. THEY
PARTICIPATE IN THE LAKE COUNTY
MEDICAL, MEDICAL CONSORTIUM WITH
SIX OTHER TRIBES. AND THIS IS
ACTUALLY THE LAST TRIBE THAT
WOULD HAVE A GAMING FACILITY OR
GAMING OPPORTUNITIES IN, IN LAKE
COUNTY. SO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THIS IS ON
BEHALF OF CHAIRMAN AUGUSTINE
GARCIA AND THE ELEM EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GREETINGS TO THE
CHAIRMAN, PLEASE. ON MY BEHALF,
I DID REPRESENT YOU IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY FROM 2014 TO 2016. SO
HAVING HEARD ALL THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONIES, MEMBERS, ARE THERE
ANY FINAL QUESTIONS ON THIS
COMPACT, SEEING NONE, THAT
CONCLUDES OUR INFORMATION
HEARING ON THE M INDIAN COLONY
COMPACT. WE'LL NOW MOVE TO THE
LA POSTA COMPACT. MR. LEE, FEEL
FREE TO BEGIN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, THIS COMPACT IS FOR A
TRIBE THAT HAD A PREVIOUS
COMPACT AND I BELIEVE HAD BEEN
GAMING IS CURRENTLY NOT GAMING,
BUT IS, LOOKING TO REPLACE ITS
COMPACT IN ANTICIPATION OF
POTENTIAL GAMING ACTIVITY IN THE
FUTURE. THE FRAMEWORK THAT THIS
COMPACT WOULD PROVIDE FOR THE,
FOR THAT GAMING ACTIVITY IS,
COMPARABLE TO CAMPO IN TERMS OF
SIZE. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A 1200
DEVICE COMPACT HERE. IN THIS
CASE, IT WOULD BE 1200 DEVICES
ACROSS A MAXIMUM OF THREE
FACILITIES, IF WE DID SEE THE
TRIBE EXCEED THAT 350 DEVICE
THRESHOLD, THAT IS OUR SORT OF
BENCHMARK FOR LOCAL, THE
POTENTIAL MITIGATION OF LOCAL
IMPACTS. THEN WE WOULD SEE THE
TRIBE PAY INTO A LOCAL
MITIGATION FUND, COULD INCLUDE
THINGS LIKE LOCAL FIRE
PROTECTION DISTRICTS AND OTHER,
OTHER LOCAL EMERGENCY SERVICES
THAT WOULD BE, I BELIEVE, 0.5%
OF WHEN, BECAUSE IT'S A 1200
DEVICE CAP, THERE ARE NO RCF
CONTRIBUTIONS HERE. THERE'S THE
STANDARD SDF. THAT'S THAT'S THE
STATE, STATE SPECIAL
DISTRIBUTION FUND, PRO RATA
FORMULA STANDARD, EMPLOYEE AND
TORT LIABILITY INSURANCE
REQUIREMENTS. OTHER STANDARD
EMPLOYEE PROTECTIONS, INCLUDING
THE TRIBAL LABOR RELATIONS
ORDINANCE. THANK YOU, MR. LEE.
I'M NOT SEEING ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM OUR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. WE'LL NOW MOVE TO
VICE CHAIRMAN HILL, WHO I
BELIEVE IS HERE IN THE ROOM.
VICE CHAIRMAN. WELCOME. AND FEEL
FREE TO BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING, VICE
CHAIRMAN FOR LA POSTA, I WAS
INVOLVED IN THE ORIGINAL COMPACT
IN 2003, AND, YOU DON'T LOOK A
DAY OLDER. THANK YOU. ANYWAYS,
THE, JUST HERE TO PRESERVE OUR
RIGHT TO GAME THE FUTURE. LIKE I
SAID EARLIER, THE, WE CLOSED
DOWN IN 2012, HOPEFULLY THINGS
WILL CHANGE. AND, WE'VE HAD,
APPRECIATE THE, THE NEGOTIATION
PROCESS, THAT YOU GUYS HAVE
PROVIDED HERE. SO HOPEFULLY WE
CAN, GET THIS BACK AND BACK IN
LINE. COULD YOU HELP US, LIKE,
EXACTLY WHERE YOU'RE LOCATED?
AND THEN DO YOU HAVE PLANS TO
BUILD A CASINO THERE? SO WE ARE
62 MILES EAST FROM SAN DIEGO,
ACTUALLY RIGHT ACROSS THE
FREEWAY FROM CAMPO. AND, RIGHT
NOW, WE HAVE CURRENTLY NO PLANS
TO OPEN THE CASINO THERE.
THAT'S, CLOSED DOWN IS JUST
STILL SITTING, SO HOPEFULLY
SOMETHING WILL CHANGE AS WE GO
DOWN THE LINE FOR THE FUTURE
GENERATIONS. FANTASTIC. MR. VICE
CHAIRMAN, THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANYBODY WISHING TO ASK ANY
QUESTIONS? SEEING NONE.
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME HERE. NOW
WE'LL MOVE TO ANYONE WANTING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS ON THIS
COMPACT. SEEING NONE, WE'LL NOW
THAT CONCLUDES OUR HEARING ON
THE LA POSTA COMPACT. WE'LL NOW
MOVE TO THE TIMBISHA COMPACT.
MR. LEE, FEEL FREE TO BEGIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, THIS
COMPACT IS ACTUALLY
SUBSTANTIVELY IDENTICAL TO THE
LA POSTA COMPACT THAT WAS JUST
DISCUSSED. I FIGURED IT WOULD
MAKE IT A LITTLE EASIER ON
EVERYONE TO TAKE THESE TWO
TOGETHER. THIS IS ANOTHER TRIBE
THAT IS NOT CURRENTLY GAMING, IT
RECENTLY HAD LAND TAKEN INTO
TRUST FOR GAMING PURPOSES NEAR
RIDGECREST. IN ADDITION TO ITS
INITIAL RESERVATION IN THE DEATH
VALLEY REGION, THE COMPACT WOULD
ALLOW FOR, GAMING ON THAT
RIDGECREST PARCEL. AND, IN
THEORY, ALSO IN DEATH VALLEY
JUNCTION. ALTHOUGH AS FAR AS I'M
AWARE, THE TRIBE HAS NO PLANS AT
THIS TIME FOR GAMING THERE. THE
SUBSTANTIVE TERMS COMPLETELY
IDENTICAL TO THE COMPACT WE JUST
DISCUSSED, BUT HAPPY TO HAPPY TO
UNPACK THOSE FURTHER OR ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I SEE NO QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS. I BELIEVE THE
CHAIRWOMAN, CORTEZ, MAY BE ON
THE ZOOM LINE. CAN WE CHECK AND
SEE PLEASE? GOOD MORNING, I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO THANK YOU
GUYS. AND THE GOVERNOR AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND MARK LEE
AND MATTHEW LEE. AND I'M A
LITTLE NERVOUS, NOEL FISHER AND
THE, GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
CONSULTANT, MR. LOPEZ. AND, BY
GETTING THIS, COMPACT DONE, WE
WILL BRING ECONOMIC Tê
DEVELOPMENT TO OUR TRIBE SO THAT
WE WILL BE ABLE TO BETTER,
SUPPORT OUR PEOPLE AND ALSO THE
COMMUNITY THAT'S DOWN THERE. AND
SO YOUR VOTE FOR SB 931 IS
SOMETHING WE WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, CHAIRWOMAN.
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE COMPACT,
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO ANYONE
WANTING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT PROCESS, SEEING NOBODY
COME FORWARD. THAT CONCLUDES OUR
HEARING ON THE COMPACT. WE'LL
NOW MOVE TO OUR FINAL INFO.
HEARING THE TULE RIVER COMPACT.
MR. LEE, FEEL FREE TO BEGIN,
PLEASE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
CHAIRMAN. THIS COMPACT IS
ACTUALLY MORE LIMITED THAN IT
MIGHT FIRST SEEM. THIS IS
ACTUALLY AN UPDATE TO A COMPACT
THAT WAS, NEGOTIATED BACK IN
2020, WHAT WE DID HERE WAS WE
AMENDED AND RESTATED THE
COMPACT, WHICH IS A FANCY WAY OF
SAYING WE COPIED AND PASTED THE
ENTIRE THING, EVEN THOSE PARTS
OF IT THAT WE WEREN'T CHANGING.
SO IT LOOKS MORE EXTENSIVE THAN
IT REALLY IS. THE CHANGES TO
THIS COMPACT COMPARED TO THE
2020 COMPACT ARE ACTUALLY QUITE
LIMITED, AND THEY ARE, FOR
BETTER OR FOR WORSE, BASICALLY
COMPELLED BY LAW. I SAID AT THE
TOP OF THE HOUR THAT THERE IS A
FEDERAL STATUTE HERE, THE INDIAN
GAMING REGULATORY ACT, THAT
PROVIDES A STRUCTURED FRAMEWORK
FOR THESE COMPACTS. THERE IS THE
SHORT VERSION IS THAT THERE IS A
LIST OF PARTICULAR TOPICS THAT
THE STATE AND THE TRIBE ARE
ALLOWED TO BARGAIN OVER. THERE
HAS BEEN SOME RECENT CASE LAW, A
CASE THAT THE NINTH CIRCUIT
COURT OF APPEALS DECIDED AFTER
THE 2020 COMPACT WITH, TULE
RIVER THAT, HAS SIGNIFICANTLY
RESTRICTED THE STATE'S ABILITY
TO BARGAIN OVER CERTAIN TOPICS
THAT IT USED TO INCLUDE IN ITS
COMPACT. NEGOTIATIONS, IN
PARTICULAR, THIS UPDATE DOES
THREE THINGS TO BRING THIS
COMPACT INTO LINE WITH THE STATE
OF THE LAW, AS IT'S BEEN
ARTICULATED BY THE NINTH
CIRCUIT. FIRST, IT DELETES TWO
PROVISIONS THAT THE NINTH
CIRCUIT HAS SAID THE STATE,
CANNOT MAINTAIN, CANNOT CONTINUE
TO NEGOTIATE FOR CONSISTENT,
CONSISTENT WITH IGRA, OUR
COMPACTS HAVE HISTORICALLY
REQUIRED TRIBAL COURT
ENFORCEMENT OF CERTAIN FAMILY
LAW ORDERS, AND OUR COMPACTS
HAVE ALSO, REQUIRED TRIBES TO,
ADOPT VERY BROAD, TORT,
LIABILITY PROTECTIONS BASED ON
CALIFORNIA LAW. THIS UPDATED
COMPACT ELIMINATES THE FAMILY
LAW PROVISION SIMPLY BECAUSE THE
NINTH CIRCUIT HAS SAID THAT WE
CAN'T DO THAT, AND IT DOES NOT
ELIMINATE THE TORT PROVISION.
BUT IT SIGNIFICANTLY NARROWS IT
IN A WAY THAT IS MORE TAILORED
TO ACTUAL PATRONS OF THE GAMING
FACILITY AND THEREFORE MORE
TETHERED TO, TO THAT GAMING
ACTIVITY. AND IN A WAY THAT WE
HOPE AND EXPECT WILL BE MORE
LIKELY TO SURVIVE FURTHER LEGAL
SCRUTINY IN THE FUTURE. THE
OTHER THING THAT THIS COMPACT
DOES, THE OTHER MAIN THING THIS
COMPACT DOES IS THE NINTH
CIRCUIT HAS SAID THAT WE CANNOT
IMPOSE, BROAD ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW, REQUIREMENTS ONTO TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS. SO RATHER THAN DO
THAT, THIS COMPACT TRIES TO
MANAGE THE POTENTIAL, OFF
RESERVATION IMPACTS OF A GAMING
OPERATION IN A DIFFERENT WAY.
THIS COMPACT IS IN MANY WAYS,
ONE OF THE MODELS FOR THE IMPACT
MITIGATION FUND THAT I HAVE
MENTIONED A FEW TIMES. THIS
MORNING. AND SO IF THE TRIBE
WERE TO OPERATE MORE THAN 350
GAMING DEVICES, THEN IT WILL
DISTRIBUTE 0.5% OF ITS NET
NGUYEN TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
ALSO TO IMPACTED LOCAL
CHARITABLE ORGANIZATIONS, AS AN
ALTERNATIVE WAY TO ADDRESS THOSE
POTENTIAL OFF SITE IMPACTS. SO,
RELATIVELY LIMITED CHANGES IN A
CONTEXT WHERE LEGALLY, OUR HANDS
ARE LARGELY TIED BY THE NINTH
CIRCUIT, BUT WE ARE STILL DOING
WHAT WE CAN TO COME UP WITH MORE
TAILORED, MORE TARGETED
STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS THE
STATE'S LEGITIMATE INTERESTS
RELATED TO THE POTENTIAL
NEGATIVE EXTERNALITIES OF GAMING
ACTIVITY WITHIN THAT FRAMEWORK.
THANK YOU, MR. LEE. SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM OUR
MEMBERS, WE'LL NOW MOVE TO VICE
CHAIRMAN KHÓ, WHO IS HERE IN
PERSON. I BELIEVE. GOOD MORNING,
MR. VICE CHAIRMAN. MORNING. GOOD
MORNING. PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
BEGIN. AND I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU GUYS FOR HEARING US OUT, YOU
KNOW, THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE,
MR. DODD, AND THE REST OF YOU, I
JUST WANT TO LET YOU GUYS KNOW
THAT, YOU KNOW, WITH THIS GAMING
COMPACT, WE, WE HAVE A LOT OF
JOBS OFFERED IN TULARE COUNTY.
IT'S ONE OF THE POOREST COUNTIES
IN AMERICA. SO YOU KNOW, WE GOT
LIKE, 964 WORKERS AT OUR CASINO
THAT THAT COUNT ON US EVERY DAY.
AND THEN THE MONEY THAT WE DO
HAVE, WE CREATED MORE JOBS ON
OUR RESERVATION TO SUSTAIN
OURSELVES, TO MAKE PEOPLE GO TO
WORK. SO A LOT OF OUR MONEY
DON'T GO TOWARDS OUR PEOPLE,
TOWARDS A TOWARDS PER CAPITA. IT
GOES TOWARDS MAKING OUR PEOPLE
STAND UP AND GET JOBS AND, AND
DO A LOT OF THINGS. SO, YOU
KNOW, AND WE ALSO BEEN GIVEN TO
THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES, YOU KNOW,
ALL THROUGHOUT TULARE COUNTY AND
THEN SOME, YOU KNOW, AND THEN WE
ALSO SUPPORT, PEOPLE LIKE OUR,
OUR GREAT, BRO. FONG THAT LEFT
YOU GUYS TO GO TO DC, YOU KNOW?
SO, WE DO A LOT OF THINGS WITH
OUR REVENUE THAT THAT MOST
DON'T. SO, YOU KNOW, I JUST WANT
TO THANK YOU GUYS TO, FOR
LISTENING TO US FROM TULE RIVER
AND LETTING US KNOW THAT, YOU
KNOW, YOU GUYS ARE HERE AND, YOU
KNOW, NOT TRYING TO PUSH TOO
MUCH ON US, BUT WE GIVE A LOT OF
THINGS THAT MOST PEOPLE DON'T
GIVE. SO, YOU KNOW, WE JUST WANT
TO KEEP MOVING AND HAVE THINGS
FOR OUR FUTURE GENERATIONS TO
COME. SO THANK YOU, MR. VICE
CHAIRMAN. APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE TODAY. THANK YOU GUYS.
THANK YOU. YOU GUYS HAVE A GOOD
DAY. WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO ANYONE
WANTING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. SEEING NONE. THAT
CONCLUDES OUR INFO HEARING ON
THE TULE RIVER COMPACT. I WANT
TO THANK MR. LEE FOR HIS HELP ON
THESE COMPACTS. AND OF COURSE,
TO ALL THE WITNESSES WHO
TESTIFIED HERE TODAY. WITH THAT,
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION IS NOW
ADJOURNED.